anyway so much should happen happy
halloween man
happy halloween yeah how would you do
how how's the project going
oh yeah how to feel to get it released
and oh so that's why i want to
bring that up because i jokingly sent
that to i think i sent that to
to garrett i was like me when the ep
bombs and it's like
my views we're getting suppressed out
here
yes i love it it's done pretty good it's
almost like across everything it's
almost at a million which is like watch
oh it is yeah awesome no that's way more
than i thought i was amazing i thought
it was gonna be like track one hella
plays
still in double digits like this has
been out for a week and
it has eight plays that's so funny drag
one hundred thousand
track two eight and a half it's like
damn oh
people really didn't like the first one
what's what's weird is track one it's
completion it's like 98
so people just get right to the end and
they're like i've had enough i hated it
it's like i can't believe how bad this
is i have to listen they're just talking
through it
it's terrible this is so [ __ ] it
keeps getting worse too oh i think it's
almost over okay
oh whoops i went to the next one yeah
but yeah you know it's yeah almost a
mill so i'm happy with that
yeah that's awesome that's [ __ ] great
yeah i showed it to my dad and
that's the first time in my entire life
he's made the stink face
like yeah to like about something i made
like we were listening to the second
track in the car
and i had it up pretty loud and he just
turns to me taps my shoulder he
but he goes makes like the stink face
like
like just holding up his hand i don't
know what he was doing with his hand it
like started as like the okay thing and
then it just like
collapsed it just
it just goes back he starts playing an
air base to it
yeah he's like damn son this is a
thumper
he was he just shook his head he was
just saying words he was like oh
perfect just so clean ding dong
son we got a thumper here it's like ted
what are you doing
it [ __ ] him up man he didn't know what
to do he was just
he just yeah just rock just you know
and and the only you know i [ __ ]
the only comment that pissed me off was
the dude was like your father would be
disappointed i was like this close to
being like i have you know he
loved it [ __ ] that's a mean comment
yeah i felt like going in on that kid i
was like [ __ ] you speak for yourself
that's really mean yeah i was [ __ ] you
jesus christ dude [ __ ] you [ __ ]
damn people suck yeah wow so yeah he was
he was geeked
and then you know um my mom was saying
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
i was like you need to relax like what
she's like dude you're like post malone
i was like um
[Laughter]
i was like mom just that's what you want
to hear from your mom though yeah i was
like i just have this coffee let's
let's be real yeah no because you know
my mom when she
when she gets like an idea in her head
it's just now
i wouldn't be surprised if you call me
tomorrow she's like i have a whole tour
routed
i told them you're post malone you know
it would i would have put it past my mom
to sell a bunch of promoters on post
malone
coming to perform yeah and then i show
up yeah they're like you're
you're like they're like no i'm post no
alone
post
[Laughter]
yeah so yeah yeah anyway um so yeah
that's
that's good what were you gonna say you
were about to say some [ __ ] and i cut
you off
which i don't know we were joking about
ah [ __ ] halloween halloween yes
yes what'd you do nothing
yeah we had four people over we no we
played we played giant jenga
you ever played jenga yeah no dude i had
a big one uh
i saw you hit nice tower oh yeah yeah
yeah thanks bro yeah thanks
clean great perfect
great stack of wood there dude i loved
your wood man
really great you guys did a nice job
with that wood
elena and i went to like mexico a while
back and
we were we just drink just getting
wasted playing giant jenga no yeah so i
love that [ __ ]
did it have the rules on it was it one
of those uh
or was it just django no it's just jenga
so you know it's pretty cool
it's like every time it comes with
permanent markers so like every time you
pull a blank one which at the start is
every single
one but then you write a rule on it and
then you play again
and like you know the drunker you get
the more stupid rules you write and then
like
eventually you have a tower full of just
ridiculous rules so every time you pull
a brick something crazy happens
just you know something crazy isn't
someone just screams or like
farts or like you know this picture in
like a group of
you know just homies or whatever and
some dude's trying to like slide to a
chick and he's like someone has to you
know
she has to kiss me and she pulls it
she's like oh my god
you know she's just happy yeah you're
crazy
oh ew stop you wrote this
gross it's guys guys let's focus on like
rules we'd actually do
then she kisses another guy in the group
makes out with him
he's like yeah who wrote that rule
anyways oh you guys are really going at
it
so did you still want me to take you
home because like i brought you here so
oh we did a [ __ ] what'd you guys do
um we did a [ __ ]
impromptu costume contest on stream
and that's pretty cool you know people
did their thing but the funniest part
was someone's like
i was like a couple days before some
dude's like yo man i'm going to my first
big college halloween party
i was like can you guys do that right
now oh people were partying dude yeah
yeah instagram stories it was like
[ __ ] up like nothing's happening
i'm not gonna air anyone out but yeah so
some people we know
it was like are you are you good yeah
loud
like rooftop bars okay i couldn't
believe that was happening oh i was
seeing like
indoor indoor parties with like 500
people
[Music]
hot i mean i feel like people are just
at the point now where they're like
i'm just gonna get it yeah i'm just
gonna [ __ ] get it yeah
yeah which is wild which is wild because
also cases are skyrocketing now in the
states you see that yeah
temperature's going down people are
staying inside cases are going
way up again la had like the biggest we
had a hundred thousand cases in the us
in one day like
four days ago wow wow that's actually
insane it was our highest
yeah [ __ ] uh london or england
is going back and back into lockdown
yeah there's some
i saw uh never mind actually probably
can't say that uh-oh
um but
but um what the [ __ ] was we're just
talking about
halloween did you watch any scary movies
um
no we didn't what was that oh yeah i was
going to talk i was going to say
our costumes kelsey and i we because
last year we were in
new orleans yeah yeah oh were we yeah
i think yeah we went to bourbon street
and everyone was dressed up
right or maybe it was
two like a couple days before halloween
that we were on bourbon street that
would make sense
kelsey and i bought like new orleans
shirts and beads
and we were like so this year we're
going to be new orleans guys nice for
for halloween you know
double new orleans where's bourbon
street yeah women awards is a bourbon
street
nice new orleans taurus i guess yeah
yeah yeah so you were people from
another place touring touring yeah
coming to new orleans for the first time
you know drinking a hand grenade
and we didn't we never wore them we
never wore the costume so this year we
were like [ __ ] what should we be and
then we're like wait a minute
we go in the closet it's like a little
brown bag in there
open it up new orleans guys
a couple of guys you catch the saints
game
i'm from uh tuscaloosa but you know i
just
i saw the game was on earlier and i was
wondering if you caught it because
you're from here right i'm not from here
do you know where i can get a great
shrimp po
boy where can i get one of those
you ever heard a choke down popeye's
it's down the street
it is so good
the only memory i have from that place
and i always bring it up
is that lady getting into it with chris
about baseball
and she was just heavy ghost drows ghost
rose she was the first lady i thought of
when they got caught cheating i was like
yeah
yeah
go stroke shut up she's like it's rigged
it's rigged yeah you guys rigged it
you